[Music]
on this thursday night toronto's mayor
makes a pandemic
plea stay home new dire projections for
what's coming in ontario
and new restrictions in alberta but not
the circuit breaker doctors pleaded for
should ottawa invoke its emergency
powers the push
wake up young trudeau and the push back
we don't need the nanny state telling us
what to do a cautionary tale from italy
hospital emergency rooms are overflowing
again could this be coming to canada
and in ontario first nations water
crisis and look at all that sludge
in here new promises to clean up the
problem met
with long-standing skepticism
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
there is no good news tonight about how
the bulk of this country is handling the
second wave of covid19
many hot spots with the exception of the
atlantic bubble and the north are
confronting
a situation that is worse than the first
wave
nothing about the virus has changed from
the spring we know the best way to stop
its spread
right now is to stop people from coming
into contact with each other
here's the overall picture more than 4
900 new cases have been confirmed in
canada today
more than 80 more people have died
apart from atlantic canada which has
sealed itself off and the territories
case numbers are surging both british
columbia and ontario broke
daily case records today in manitoba the
worst per capita in the country there
were more than 470 new cases
in alberta tonight premier jason kenny
is back in self-isolation after coming
into contact with someone
who has covid19 case numbers there are
surging the number of albertans
hospitalized with covid19
has hit a record high there are now 51
people in intensive care
up from 30 a little more than a week ago
more than 400 doctors have pleaded with
kenny to impose
circuit breaker restrictions to stop the
spread today
he didn't do that no businesses have
been told to shut their doors but bars
and restaurants must close
by 11 pm this two-week push
is i believe our last chance to
avoid more restrictive measures that i
and most albertans desperately want to
avoid
as heather urix west explains there are
fears without tougher restrictions now
the health system
could soon be in crisis after a summer
of relative calm
doctors within alberta's health system
are preparing for a battle
for weeks the number of daily infections
has been rising
and now many of the patients are in need
of hospital care
i think everybody knows what's going to
happen within the hospitals everyone is
scared of what's going to happen
the escalation in the last week alone
has been startling
between november 4th and 11th there were
more than 5 000 new infections
53 new hospitalizations and 16
additional patients sent to the icu
it's likely that in 10 days time
that will be maybe not quite doubled but
supposing we have 80 patients in the icu
the icu system will collapse we are at a
dangerous
juncture in our province alberta's
premier who is again isolating after
being exposed to covet 19
agrees the situation is serious but
believes
targeted measures will be enough to bend
the curve down
we think it's necessary at this time to
bring in limited
focused targeted measures
that reduces opportunities for viral
spread
without imposing uh significant broader
negative impacts on our society on
uh lives and livelihoods emergency room
doctor joe vipan fears the measures will
not be enough
really i don't think the government has
quite grasped the seriousness of where
we're at and
the depth of what we need to do in order
to get out of this
dr vypond is among more than 400 alberta
physicians calling for a short
sharp period of lockdown how long may
depend on how bad the problem is allowed
to get
the idea that alberta can take a two
week time out
and hey presto covet will be under
control is foolhardy
you're going to have to take two months
not two weeks
because you have climbed the mountain so
high
that it takes that amount of time to
reach the bottom on the other side
because the people in hospital now were
infected weeks ago
so we don't yet know how serious the
situation in alberta
truly is heather urex west global news
calgary
in canada's biggest city community
spread is out of control toronto has
record levels of covid19 now and
today the city's mayor had a blunt
message for people
stay home stay home work from home
study from home don't go out except to
shop once a week by yourself
don't you know go out to do anything
unnecessary
ontario's premier though has resist
reimposing tough restrictions
new modeling released today shows that
province is headed down a dangerous path
the new projections predict given how
fast the virus is spreading
ontario could have 6 500 cases per day
by mid-december
and under every scenario in those models
the province's icu capacity is expected
to be threatened
within just two weeks the projections
are dire and yet ontario's premier says
the economic risks of another lockdown
are too great
eric sorenson reports two mid-october
weddings here were linked weeks later to
around
50 confirmed cases of covet 19. but it's
not just
big events in hot zones like the greater
toronto area
many ontario health regions are counting
more coveted cases
the pandemic is worsening in the weeks
ahead a projected five percent rate of
covet growth in ontario would likely
exceed the rate in some european
countries
that are already in some form of
lockdown new ontario modeling shows
hospitalizations in gold have risen
61 percent in the last three weeks
patients in icu beds have almost reached
100
the province projects icu occupancy will
exceed 150 beds within two weeks
in a worst-case scenario it would exceed
400 beds in six weeks time
seriously straining ontario's capacity
to care for acutely ill
kovid patients those projections as you
said are alarming
you need to return to what we did during
the first wave you need to return
to that household limitation a group of
ontario doctors says this province must
do more now to flatten the curve
we're recommending that people stop all
non-essential services
including public events of course so
that we can gain control of the spread
while we strengthen public health
measures
ontario's opposition leader called for a
two-week circuit breaker for hot spots
like toronto
a brief but thorough lockdown to stop
the spread
but ontario's premier says he has to
balance the health of ontarians
and the economy he does not want a
lockdown how can he measure
the the depression the mental health of
businesses
and the owners when all of a sudden they
go belly up there has to be a balance
priority number one on health and safety
but very close beside it is the economy
ontario prepared to open more widely
this weekend but toronto said no to
reopening indoor dining
it's led to mixed messaging the premier
wants the economy open
while toronto's mayor says this please
stay home as much as you can
if you have any doubt about whether you
really need to go somewhere or not
don't go stay home it's a hard needle to
thread
how to patronize businesses to keep the
economy afloat
while being urged to stay home eric
sorenson global news toronto
bc updated its covid 19 modeling today
too it is projecting new cases could
double in the next
13 days unless people reduce who they
come into contact with
hospitalization numbers in bc are
already above the peak they were this
spring
nbc's provincial health officer says the
majority of new cases can be traced to
household gatherings
and community interaction we started to
see young people again
driving infection in the province
whether it's through
social interactions primarily whether
it's through work
interactions and what we're seeing now
is spill over
into older age groups where people are
more vulnerable
manitobans are living under the tightest
restrictions they faced since the
pandemic began the entire province is in
the critical red zone now
the test positivity rate in winnipeg is
11.4 percent that is the worst in the
country
and the message there too is stay home
if we follow these orders don't try to
find ways around them
don't try to find ways that manitobans
can gather we'll start to see these
numbers
come down as we did before
under the new restrictions manitoba
schools will remain open but most
non-essential retail stores
gyms hair salons and houses of worship
are closed and people are being
urged to avoid all non-essential travel
the provinces have been calling for more
federal financial support and there's
some pressure on the prime minister to
take action
and invoke federal emergency legislation
but that is a step
too far for premiers like ontario's doug
ford
david aiken explains it's concerning
it's alarming and we have to stay on
high alert
but are those alarming spikes coming
from schools
from restaurants gyms the science on
that is evolving it's a complicated
question
and data is complicated but scientists
are crystal clear on this
we know that covid spreads in the
following conditions a bunch of people
together shared air space limited
ventilation
no masks all we need to do is make those
situations stop
but who will make it stop some say
now is the time for the prime minister
to step up
his dad used emergency powers for
inflation
his but he won't do it for a pandemic
wake up young trudeau you have an
emergency and you need to use emergency
powers
but the man himself disagrees i don't
see it as being necessary right now
and if he did the prime minister would
get grief from the premiers
that wouldn't go over too well not just
with me with uh all 12 other
premiers the more common view among
public health experts is that
local health authorities should prevail
who do we listen to
i think really we should be listening to
our local municipalities
that know what's happening know what the
rates are but there is still plenty for
ottawa to do for example
health canada could respond more rapidly
to evolving technology
such as home testing kits if we could
have an approved
home testing kit for covid that we could
use as a screening tool
that we could actually bring this
pandemic to an end
now the prime minister and the premiers
met by teleconference today but
they were not expected to talk about an
expanded role for ottawa but the
premiers were expected to ask the pm
yet again for more cash to fight the
coronavirus
donna all right david aiken in ottawa
thank you
in the u.s the pandemic is now worse
than it has ever been
almost every metric is trending in the
wrong direction and records are being
broken every day in nearly every
american state
more than 143 000 new infections were
recorded across the u.s
on wednesday that is the highest single
day tally more than 65 000 americans are
in the hospital that's more than at any
time since the pandemic began
hospitals are running out of beds new
jersey's governor is pleading with
people to choose inconvenience
over death jackson proskow on america's
surging second wave in el paso texas
they've brought in a fourth mobile
morgue as the death rate soars
in wisconsin hospitals have reached
capacity
in ohio which reported 7 thousand new
cases thursday
the governor warned businesses may soon
be forced to close
it's advancing quickly and seeking
victims in every community in ohio
yet as the virus spreads like wildfire
the white house is silent
the coronavirus task force has
effectively gone dark
there's a viral killer going on
in each of our communities if it were
an army with guns you can be sure
we would be focused on it why aren't we
focused
on this virus instead in the final 69
days of his presidency
donald trump is blocking president-elect
joe biden from accessing key government
health agencies
and data as part of his refusal to
concede
candidly the president and his closest
advisors when they're not
actively being infected or infecting
others with the coronavirus
have been doing nothing at current rates
the u.s is on track to record another
150
000 deaths before biden's inauguration
in late january
without access to government data
medical experts warn
the biden administration will be left
playing catch-up on day one
despite assembling a panel of experts in
advance
they are going to have plans they are
going to have strategies but without
understanding the current status of
what's happening inside the agencies
they're going to have to be doing it
flying blind
it's clear the promise of a vaccine in
2021
won't be enough to get the u.s through
the difficult months ahead
new york is approaching its self-imposed
threshold for shutting schools down
again and chicago
issued a renewed stay at home advisory
while americans face the prospect of
explosive case growth
as millions prepare to travel and gather
for the busy thanksgiving holiday
jackson costco global news washington
the second wave hits italy hard coming
up the overwhelmed hospitals
and the building frustration
at the start of the pandemic we all
watched with horror what was happening
in italy and hoped it wouldn't happen
here well now italy is fully engulfed in
a second wave
in the last 24 hours nearly 38 000
people
have tested positive and more than six
hundred people have died
hospitals are overwhelmed again and it's
a cautionary tale
for all of us crystal gamansing reports
at this hospital in naples it's curbside
care
for at least four days staff have been
treating patients
in their cars checking blood pressure
even administering oxygen
and it's not the only hospital in
southwestern italy making headlines
a video spreading on social media
appears to show a corpse on the floor of
a bathroom
the director general of the carterelli
hospital says an investigation
is underway into the death lacosa
it's correct he says that people know of
certain things but what is deplorable
is the way in which the communication
was given
naples and the entire calabria region is
struggling to cope with rising covet 19
cases
more than 4 000 people there tested
positive in the past 24 hours
yet it is listed as yellow on the
country's tiered system of restrictions
five italian medical organizations
signed a letter warning of the dire
situation playing out
saying hospitals are now close to
collapse
adding a probable if not certain
consequence will be the inability to
guarantee
quality standards for care for all
chronically ill
and non-covet acute patients italian
prime minister giuseppe conte has
resisted imposing
another national lockdown speaking at a
summit for world
leaders it doesn't appear he'll be
changing course
we needed to look beyond the emergency
and focus our global
action on fostering an inclusive
sustainable and resilient recovery
a sustainable and resilient recovery
means little to this woman
her father died after testing positive
for covin 19 and she's
angry because he wasn't admitted to
hospital right away
doctors warn of an additional 10 000
deaths in a month's time
if the government doesn't introduce more
restrictions
crystal gamansen global news london
in new zealand a mysterious case of
covid19 is being investigated an
auckland woman tested positive for the
virus but officials aren't sure how she
got it
she's a university student she lives
beside a hotel where people arriving
from abroad are being quarantined
health officials are trying to work out
if there is a connection people who work
in central auckland have been told to
stay home
until the cause of transmission is
determined
still ahead ottawa answers building
demands to probe contractors working on
a first nations water crisis
you're watching global national
[Music]
promises are being made again to fix the
water crisis on a remote northern
ontario first nation
people living on the neshtanaga first
nation have had to boil their drinking
water for 25 years now
last month things got even worse an oily
substance was found in the water supply
and the community was evacuated
the federal government says a fix is
coming but as michael couture explains
the chief
isn't buying it and look at all that
sludge
in here that sludge and sheen on the
water are why most people from the
niskanen first nation
had to be flown out of the territory
weeks ago
derrick munoz is one of the few left
behind
he goes house to house making sure
sewers don't back up
more than they already have it's just
you know daily routines three times a
day i check certain houses
and takes a lot of out of me to
try to clean that he does it to help his
community
a community that has been without clean
drinking water for 25 years
things reached a breaking point last
month when an oily sheen was spotted in
the water reservoir
but now it seems the federal government
has a solution
in a letter to niskanen first nation
chief chris muniz dated november 6
indigenous services minister mark miller
said quote
clean drinking water should be available
in your community
by december 11 2020 but the chief
isn't buying it just given a report
yesterday that
repatriation will not happen until
december 2.
so i don't think that's going to meet
the timelines that minister
miller has indicated munoz says when his
people return home they worry the water
can only be used for things like
flushing toilets and washing clothes
ndp mp charlie angus worries this will
only be a temporary fix
because the infrastructure needs a
massive makeover
it's like they're claiming they're going
to put a new engine into a rotted old
uh vehicle and then think that the
vehicle is going to run the the pipes
the um
the the sewage systems they are all are
all completely out of date
chief muniz claims the tendering process
is flawed and that major pipe problems
were never
fixed it's why he demanded an
investigation
of the business practices of companies
that worked on their water treatment
plant
something the liberal government has
also agreed to
and the chief hopes it will mean an end
to the boil water advisory
that started in 1995. 25 years 26 years
is dehumanizing
are we not human are we not important
mike lacrouter global news
the bot who cried wolf next a high-tech
bear repellent
[Music]
quite an unveiling in turkmenistan this
week a statue of a big golden
dog has been given a prime location in
the capital city of the former soviet
republic
it is the pet project of the president
of turkmenistan who loves
this particular breed the central asian
shepherd
so much in fact he's written a book
about them and he gave a puppy to the
russian president vladimir putin
he also apparently oversaw construction
of this statue it's 15 meters high it
has a screen
showing videos of the breed meanwhile
much of the country lives
in poverty
and in japan look at this this statue
moves
and growls it's a robot wolf and it's
designed to scare away bears it's called
monster wolf and when its motion
detectors are activated it moves its
head
flashes lights and emits 60 different
sounds apparently
including wolfish howling and apparently
it works
bear sightings are at a five-year high
mostly in rural areas in western and
northern japan
there you go that is global national for
this thursday
i'm donna friesen sticking with the
animal theme tonight's your canada
is this real live moose in jasper
alberta
we'd love to see your canada please send
it to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching robin gill will be
here tomorrow and i'll see you on
saturday at 7 for the new reality
take care of yourselves bye-bye